I'm back loser party of one
now have you ever wondered why you made
so many enemies along the way sure
Audrey's behavior was next-level but she
had her reasons for being mad at you we
love how you developed over the three
descendants movies you truly became your
best self I've learned that you can't
live in fear but that doesn't mean it's
all plain sailing from here
forget enemies its frenemies that you'll
need to watch out for there can only be
one queen bee after all and there's a
certain Disney princess who will also
want that crown I have to be queen of
the Isle
too if all the characters got to hang
out together in the Disney verse not
everyone would get along there'd be some
pretty major front of me dynamics keep
watching to the end to discover which
ladies would clash over whose powers
we're the greatest Tiana and jasmine at
first glance you'd think that these two
Disney Princesses would get along just
fine but as with all the pairings on our
list when you scratch the surface you
see just how much these frenemies would
clash Tiana is the only Disney Princess
to have an actual job the heroine of The
Princess and the Frog is totally driven
to achieve her dream of owning a
restaurant and that's down to her deep
respect for her father I gotta make sure
all daddy's hard work means Jasmine on
the other hand is not interested in
following her father's advice she defies
his request and even runs away from home
Aladdin's love interest is not aware of
the rules of life in the real world like
having to pay for food off of a market
stall there you go
you'd better be able to pay for that
jasmine is all about wanting
independence from her dad and going on
adventures tiana in contrast is all
about working hard and honoring her
dad's legacy that's some pretty
fundamental differences to create a
major clash of course sometimes being
too similar can cause problems too and
that's the case with our next entry J
and Flynn Rider if anyone knows a thing
or two about stealing its descendants
very own BK turned hero J as would
tangled splint Rider
or should we say Eugene Fitzherbert
Rapunzel's Bey has also gone from being
a thief to a hero
so surely these two reformed characters
would get on perfectly we think not
you can't ignore their shared
competitive nature Jay transformed the
thrill of this deal to the thrill of the
tourney field but that need to win is
still there of course there's nothing
wrong with that however we can't help
but think that a little healthy
competition would boil over into
something more antagonistic between
these two guys sure they'd act like
friends on the outside but deep down
they'd both be trying to one-up each
other I can't believe that after all
we've been through together you don't
trust me keep watching to discover which
other Disney characters similarities
would push them apart rather than
strengthen their bond Pocahontas and
Mulan both of these Disney Princesses
broke the mold when their movies came
out in the 90s they brought different
cultures to the franchise and a fresh
outlook on what could define a princess
however that doesn't mean that they'd be
besties quite the contrary in fact
Pocahontas is a pacifist she doesn't
support violence or combat of any swords
period look around you
this is where the path of hatred has
brought us Mulan of course is a trained
soldier we can just imagine these two
arguing over their different approaches
to conflict resolution we can also
picture their sidekicks kicking off -
Pocahontas is hummingbird friend flit
could get feisty with Mulan's cricket
confidante crickey a spur dragon Mushu
and raccoon Miko there could be a fair
bit of fighting over who gets to eat all
the snacks the real question though is
which other Disney princess would take
on the role of mediator we reckon
frozen's onna would make a great
moderator but she might be too busy
dealing with her own frenemy situation
Merida and Anna Merida and Anna both
have issues with their families frozen
is a masterclass in the intricacies of
sisterly relationships while breve
expertly plays out the tensions between
mothers and daughters I'm not going to
be like you you're acting
you'd think that shared experience would
bond Maradona but we're pretty sure
these redheads would have plenty of
passive-aggressive spats Merida is a
rebel and is keen to defied the typical
role of princess is supposed to accept
she's not bothered about tearing her
family apart
or tearing apart a perfectly good
tapestry for that matter sure she makes
nice with her mom in the end but
initially she's quite happy to shame her
household by refusing to marry any of
her suitors on the flip side anna is all
about preserving the family bond Elsa
please please I can't live like this
anymore
she'd do anything for her sis including
sacrificing herself and also Merida gets
to that point in the end we just can't
see on a digging Merida sulky teenager
vibes mal and Elsa Ana's sister is a
prime candidate for having a fair few
frenemies she is one of the feistiest of
all the Disney Princesses being
determined to do things her way you
asked for my blessing but my answer is
no do you know who else is headstrong in
the Disney verse descendants very own
powerhouse mouths instead of bonding
over their shared abilities to shoot out
awesome powers these two Disney
characters would totally clash they each
want to be queen bee but when there's
only room for one at the top the gloves
would come off quite literally in Elsa's
case they might pretend like they
respect each other but deep down they'd
be plotting how to prove that they were
the most powerful of them all Dragons
don't really lose weight whose powers do
you think would win in a battle mouths
green eyed dragon might or Elsa's icy
force so that's a wrap on the Disney
characters that would be frenemies which
Disney character would be your front of
me we'd love to know so please share
with us in the comments make sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching we'll
see you soon
[Music]